foreign
according to your computer
so everybody who's seated as our regular
members
need a motion on the minutes
second
motion by Schmidt second by Lang
any additions deletions corrections to
the minutes
seeing none all those in favor
any objections
okay emotion on the consent agenda
motion by Schmidt second by McGuire
are there any changes
all those in favor
aye
any opposed
and emotion on the
postponement list which is quite
extensive I moved to postpone the items
on the
postponement lists including requesting
of the waivers necessary
motion by McGuire second by Lang Mr
chairman
um
there are two or three items that are
specifically it says postponed October
20th all the rest will be postponed to
October 6th
correct yeah
okay the regular agenda
oplc
Hey sir um this is um as you said in an
oplc rule that regulates electrologists
previously administration of these
providers was under the Department of
Health and Human Services but that
Administration was transferred to the
oplc in 2015.
the rules um that the Department of
Health and Human Services had an Hep
1300 expired on December 11 2017.
so the committee may have some questions
about that there are a few other issues
to to go through if you want I can go
ahead and start going through those and
then we can Circle back to the agency or
if you want to talk to the agency now
about the expired rules however you want
to do it sir
just go ahead you got it okay so
um besides that issue if you look on
page nine of the PDF there's just a note
there around the committee's continued
support of the executive director and
having fee Authority
there's also a note on page 12 that can
be disregarded regarding the need for
legislation as there was a house bill
1062 from last session that removed um
The Authority or the requirement of this
committee to conduct the licensee
examinations that can now be done by a
third party vendor
um and finally there there's a comment
on page 14 because the rule appears to
allow applicants and this is on a couple
of places in the rule to choose what fee
they want to pay
so the rule says
um the fee is 155 or whatever is in plc
1002.
and what's noteworthy is that the form
says the the fee is 110. so there's it's
not clear what the applicant is supposed
to pay and it's not clear if the intent
is just to allow the applicant to choose
whatever they want to pay
so um that issue also appears on another
page as well and that's in regard to the
owners of electron of these schools to
submit
um to submit a fee and to submit
information
that's on pages 27 and 28 and then 29
through 30.
um so there the owners can just submit
information in order to get that
permission that license to open their
school
oplc says there's no form for that but
it does require that the applicant
certify in a test so it's not clear how
they're supposed to do that the rule
also doesn't specify where this
information is sent whether that's email
or so oplc or Etc
so and again it also says that the
applicant can choose what to pay and um
and there's no explanation as to what
happens if the fees are different either
in this role or over in the other 1002
rule so that's at a high level the
issues with this proposal sir
good morning my name is Douglas
osterhout I'm General counselor for the
office of professional licensure and
certification as far as the fees go the
lower amount would be paid the IP for
this started in rule making prior to the
PLC 1002s being in rule making so the
specific fee was included here if it
we could revise the language to read the
renewal application processing feed
specified in PLC 1002 if that would if
that would clear things up I think that
would I think we need to make sure that
what's on the form is the same as what's
in the 1002 rule
because as I said
um the form indicates that and this is
on page 10
or 14 of the PDF if you're looking at
that 10 of the rule proposal it says the
form indicates the fuse 110 but then the
rule text says 115 or 155 but then it
says or the amount required by PLC 1002
so I think removing the application fee
here is fine but then we still need to
make sure is is it the same as what's
you know on the form
we'll make sure the form matches I'll
work with Gretchen to make sure that
happens
then I think
um
I think you were going to probably hit
down to the other issue with the owners
and the licensing
where to submit the information I think
that all starts around page 27.
so if you look at the page 28 of the
link to documents page 24 of the fixed
text document
it says the owner shall submit the
request but the processing fee of 375 or
the amount
established in 1002 if different
so again I guess maybe I think it's the
same solution we can change the language
we can revise that to the owner she'll
submit the request with the processing
fee established in PLC uh 1002
and I think the same solution would fix
both issues I think that would do it and
I think we probably need another
um paragraph in this section and this is
708.03 we need another paragraph in
there that tells the applicants where to
submit this information
I'll work with Gretchen on that and then
we need to know too how the applicant
can submit a certification statement
so I guess maybe just needs to spell
that out a little bit more clearly in
the rule so we're just looking for
clarifying language okay
good
about the fact that the Rule's been
expired for five years
unfortunately I don't have a lot of
history on that I only started in
January and as soon as the rules came
over to oplc and they became an Advisory
Board we started drafting rules to get
them in place right away
uh can I ask what you've been doing in
over the last five years regarding you
know fees and applications and licenses
and such like
do you have any history of course yeah I
wasn't expecting that question I can do
some research and I can get you an
answer but I don't have an answer for
you today
now I do know executive director
Courtney
um makes it a point not to collect fees
that she doesn't have the authority to
do so
um so that would fall in line with her
way of doing business
Mr chair I I move we object to the rule
on the grounds of Staff comments and
invite you to submit a corrective a
corrective app
proposal and also provide a report on
the
activities since the previous rules
expired
thank you Mr chair I also have another
request with that
fees support activity and they're
directed to that activity and there's
parameters that they have to stay within
and that's why those fees exist
you need authorization to charge the
fees
so here's here's my question I need to
know
the mechanisms that were utilized to
fund this activity
this is important and it has to be very
clear and explicit and if the fees were
not collected
what monies were utilized
to support this activity
because again the department had zero
Authority
to assess fees they had zero authority
to actually do anything around the
Realms of this activity
and and that's the seriousness that this
has to be held so
um am I clear in in what I would be
expecting yes sir so I want to repeat it
back to you to make sure thank you
um mechanisms that are utilized to fund
activities and if fees were not
collected what fees were utilized if in
fact the fees were not collected correct
and if they were collected I need to
know an accounting not that if that's
okay Mr chairman I will gladly accept
that amendment to my motion thank you
thank you and thank you sir I'm second
the motion
thank you motion by McGuire amendment by
hatch second by bursting
and
get finish this
um
any other discussion or questions from
the committee
seeing none all those in favor
any no
and we'll see Representatives show it
for Senator Whitley
Mr chairman yes I've been informed that
there was no vote on the postponement
issue
okay we had a motion and a second on
postponements all those in favor
aye
yeah thank you no I didn't hear it
everybody vote
okay laidac board
okay
um
this uh proposal makes changes to the
Alcohol and Other Drug use professional
rules the agency has filed a conditional
approval request which has resolved all
the issues there is just one issue and
that is related to the fact that the
rules have been expired since 2017.
foreign
McGuire
yes please explain
yes so even though these rules were
expired we relied on the
um the Department of Justice rules is
that what it was for laid out so that
there's uh rules Jus 800s which allow us
to
um hold their sort of Gap filler
catch-all for uh educated hearings under
administrative boards
oh sure uh
I was saying the Justice 800s are can be
used as they can be used as sort of Gap
filler for administrative hearings in
the event that something uh like latex
rules would lapse uh now currently
there's also the PLC 200s which went
into effect early August August 4th or
August 8th I'm not sure
if you have two sets of rules governing
this why are you putting up a third set
the the rules for oplc are
intended to be covered the
uh
a couple of reasons
are meant to cover the
advisory boards who wouldn't have rules
uh we're hoping in an effort to
streamline the system to eventually get
a lot of boards to adapt the 200 some of
those committees have already done that
I believe acupuncture has made a motion
to do that Midwifery has decided to go
in that direction and they're also used
there's language in there that they're
meant to supplement rules and not uh
circumvent or oversee so if there are
rules in the individual committees they
can also be used
foreign
would it help if I provided an example
of this sort of thing
okay so there's there's and a lot of the
statutes there's there'll be reference
to say an emergency suspension where we
a board can take action against a
licensee but they have to have a hearing
within 10 days and those are in
emergency situations what we were
finding was a lot of the rule sets while
they may have it in statute didn't have
specific rules to address how an
emergency hearing the timing those types
of things would occur so the PLC 200s
can be used in those sort of instances
and that's based on
the plcr no RSA 310
A1 d
Roman numeral two H2
which gives us the authority to
promulgate rules for those types of
processes
okay
um so what is the difference between
these
these rules and the oplc rules are these
more detailed are they more focused on
issues with latex or what
these sections across all of them
uh Tina Kelly
um program specialist with the office of
professional licensure and certification
these rules um are pretty much the same
across the various boards and
um so they're pretty standard rules that
are used and I'm and I'm guessing that
oplc has the same standard of rules they
might be worded a little bit different
but they do the same thing
if they do the same thing why duplicate
why bother why put us all through this
and energy
go ahead mom
so maybe it'd be beneficial just to
speak briefly very briefly because this
is an ongoing issue and it needs to be
rectified
um
I haven't heard the causation for the
lack of the rules being submitted in a
timely manner so is that a process
problem or what is the problem to that
Personnel problem and and maybe if you
could I'm sorry to go on but explain the
process now does these rules go to like
the governor's Council of alcohol and
drugs first and they have to go through
and and agree on said set of rules or
what is the process for that and where
are we getting tripped up and and if it
can be done in a very short period of
time and with the chairs indulgent could
we do that and that might help us
um so what has happened is we we went
back and we identified through all the
boards which rules were expiring which
rules are going to expire that process
has been now put into place what we're
doing right now is trying to get
everything caught up so as soon as all
these expired rules are caught up and we
have them adopted there's a system now
in place so that this will not happen
down the road
thank you that's what I was looking for
and and thank you for that yes that I
still have the question of even if the
op the specific
alcohol
procedural rules were expired the fact
that you've got
Department of Justice rules and oplc
rules that cover the activities
why are you bothering with to put these
through instead of just referencing the
oplc rules
so
it's it's my understanding that all
aboards have had these in place and the
boards
um determine are the ones determining
um
legal issues within their specific
boards and that what oplc is trying to
do is to work with the boards
individually to have them if they choose
move over to oplcs then these would be
revised to just refer to oplc's rules
they're trying to work collaboratively
with the boards
so there's buy it
could I um
so I mean just for clarity why there is
an additional set of rules the ones that
are out of the oplc are the different
boards such as the alcohol board are
more explicit but you're using the 200
authority to
adjudicate things under those more
explicit rules provided by the boards is
that not correct so there isn't a
duplication of verbiage the rules
are defined a little differently within
or more explicitly within the different
boards than the 200 rules is that not
correct there's it's not a duplication
per se and they're using the 200 rules
to authorize them to adjudicate under
these explicit the explicit verbiage
from the different boards is that a
correct scenario is that what we're
looking for I think yes I think so I
think so and there's right there's a
question of uh ease for for the user too
on the end so they can go right to their
rules they can look at those statutes
and if there was something that wasn't
addressed in their rules that's where
they might turn to the Justice 800s in
the past now they might turn to the PLC
200s to sort of supplement the thing
they know the thing they're comfortable
with and as Tina pointed out we are
working with the boards to try and get
everyone to adopt eventually that's a
long-term goal we'll see how it goes
Mr chairman Mr chairman yes I think Kim
can clarify this for the committee
just going to point out the uh the
statute that oplc is referring to is 310
a1-d
so that is titled administration of the
office of professional licensure and
certification specifically H2 talks
about what grants them Authority it says
such organization and procedural rules
necessary to administer the board's
commissions councils and programs in the
office including rules governing the
administration of complaints and
investigations hearings disciplinary
proceedings Payment Processing
procedures and application procedures
the boards shall retain the authority to
determine the criteria necessary for
licensing applications so that seems to
be how that is partitioned out
yep
Diane
oh I tend to agree with representative
McGuire I I'm not sure I see the need
for two sets
um but
okay
so we still need a motion to approve the
rule
so move
motion by hatch second by
e
so I can buy Schmidt
any further discussion
seeing none all those in favor
any opposed
we have three opposed
the motion carries
Board of veterinary medicine
yes sir um this proposal also makes
changes to the rules on the practice of
veterinarian medicine I don't have any
substantive comments just as the the um
the rule set that we heard before these
rules have been expired since 2020 so
the committee may want to ask some
questions about enforcement of this rule
so I know for this one there was a
mistake oplc received
um
fees for renewals last year but we are
in the process of refunding those rules
we have not been collecting fees for
initial licensure since then renewals
happen every December so the renewal
piece hasn't been an issue since last
year uh I found out about this January
February after I started we made it a
priority to get all the vet board rules
moving forward as far as discipline goes
the there was only one disciplinary
action again we could rely on the
Justice 800 rules and that was a
violation of Statute we were still able
to issue licenses renewals and initial
licenses because the statutory there's
statutory Authority that allows the oplc
to do that
uh that would be 332 B9
Mr chairman so the committee is aware
until recently the veterinary rules were
under uh the Department of Agriculture
and they have now moved over to Opel
okay
questions from the committee
seeing none
looking for a motion
motion by McGuire second by hatch
send me
I'm sorry uh
unless the staff objects that would be
for all three sets of rules so to
clarify that would be for
um well you just yes it would be for 89
90 and 102. correct yes ma'am
okay any further questions or discussion
from the committee
this is to approve
c d and e all three rules all those in
favor
perhaps we could just have uh something
from the agriculture Department to
provide the links I understand the carry
forward from agriculture department and
so forth to oplc but I think we have to
have something you know in writing that
that uh
reads to that effect
thank you
if I could please um the motion on 490
should be conditionally approved there
was a conditional approval request for
that proposal
okay we'll accept that
any further discussion from the
committee
Real Estate Commission
this proposal was conditionally approved
by the committee in July and it was
based on the agency's conditional
approval request but the response made a
number of amendments which were not part
of the conditional approval request many
of the amendments are editorial some of
them are not annotated
there are a couple of substantive
changes that could be argued either as
substantive or editorial if you look on
page six there is the deletion of a fee
but a couple of sub paragraphs before it
is a citation to that same fee so that's
why that has been deleted
um and then there's an insertion of the
word broker in quite a few places
it sounds like this was part of cleanup
by the board after the fact and then
there's a new requirement
granting permission that if a person
grants permission that um that uh a
personal email address can be can be
used and that's on page seven so
um again I have no other comments other
than just to give you a high level
summary of the changes that were made
that were not included in the
conditional approval request
questions from the committee
looking for
yes thank you do I understand you
correctly that the objection response
has what would it would generate no
objections yes ma'am I think it could be
argued um as I said one way or or the
other that these changes on page seven
of the um of the PDF
I believe that that sentence was
actually in the role further up the road
if you will I think in the final
proposal but it gotten moved out so it's
in here now
um some of the other changes appear to
be cleanup
um I think Tina can speak to why the
board chose this moment to um to make
these changes instead of having them in
the conditional approval request at the
outset
go ahead hi Tina Kelly program
specialist oplc
um I I brought it to the board I
explained to them what would happen if
they made these changes and that they
were and to only do it if it was
imperative they felt that it was
imperative they knew that they would it
would result in a preliminary objection
response and they were adamant that
these be changed for clarity's sake and
the correctness of the rules
um
they've been working on them they've
made more changes over time
why they waited to this moment to make
these few changes
I I can't answer to that they they just
noticed them is my best answer
sir if I I could too
um is just come to my attention that the
committee didn't vote on the three vet
rules I think the Motions were made but
no voting actually took place
is that correct
yeah we voted oh we got
did we yeah okay
okay
sorry Mike was thinking that we hadn't
voted I was I wasn't sure
I moved to approve
these rules
with the
second
motion by McGuire second by Lang
discussion
seeing none all those in favor
any opposed
Department of Revenue Administration
foreign
so Mr chair there were a number of
comments on this particular rule the
2022 114
um however just so the committee is
aware the agency did reach out with a
conditional approval request past the
deadline
um and so I
know um I did did initial review of that
as it does need a waiver so I couldn't
submit it as an actual conditional
approval
um
and if the agency would like to request
a waiver at this time then perhaps we
could discuss that first as it does take
care of a number of the comments okay so
you need a motion
for the waiver so move tools
motion by length second by Schmidt all
those in favor
aye
thank you Mr chair
um so the remaining comments that are on
this particular rule the first is on
page one it's just a note to the
committee that this particular agency
does have an exemption from RSA
541a
for its forms they do not have to be
incorporated by reference do not need
addition dates and maybe changed outside
of the RSA 501a process however there
were still a couple comments with regard
to the forums outside of these
parameters the first
is that a number of the forms
ask that they be signed under the
penalties
of perjury
specifically form CD 57p which is on
page first referenced on page two
cd57 s also on page 2 CD 57 hcp also on
page two
cd57 HCS also on page 2 of the rule
dp151 which appears on pages five and
six five and sixteen of the rule CD 92
which appear on page 7 and 15 of the
rule Au 202 page 10 of the rule Au 201
page 13 of the rule in dp8 which appears
on page 18 of the rule the agency has
provided the explanation that RSA
21j392d provides them with broad
authority to use penalties of perjury on
their form
however staff disagrees with this
analysis of the statute the statutory
language specifically is with respect to
any tax administered by the department
no person shall willfully make And
subscribe any return report statement or
other document that contains or is
verified by a written declaration that
is made under the penalties of perjury
and that he does not believe to be true
and correct as to every material matter
the staff would argue that this language
is stating that no person shall provide
misleading or incorrect information on a
form that already contains the
Declaration it does not give permission
for the Declaration to be included on
all forms and this is further supported
by the fact that a number of the other
forms included with this rule have
statutes that specifically allow them to
be signed under the pains and penalties
of perjury
specifically the forms that relate to
the tobacco tax RSA 7842 specifically
says the commissioner shall adopt rules
pursuant to our say 541a relative to the
form of such return in the data
which it must contain for the correct
computation of tobacco tax attributable
to the state the consumer shall sign the
return subject to the pains and
penalties of perjury this is also found
in RSA 8210 1A which is under the
taxation of railroads and similarly
similarly under RSA 83 F5 which
also has the statement
um
that the
commissioner shall require and shall be
signed by an authorized representative
subject to the pains and penalties of
perjury
the additional comments that I have for
this particular rule
um is on page two of the rule page eight
of the packet under Revenue
809.05 those forms
um
that are listed in that particular rule
are forms that are the Declaration of
consideration and the statute
regarding the Declaration of
consideration forms RSA 78 b101a does
have
specific statutory language it requires
on the form and the forms seem to admit
part of that statutory language
specifically the agree and affirm that
the full price or consideration for the
real estate transfer is x amount of
dollars instead the form State I declare
that I've examined this return to the
best of my belief it is true correct and
complete staff would argue that these
are two very different requirements and
therefore the agree and affirm should be
added to that particular form
the next comment is on page four of the
rule page 10 of the packet under Revenue
1002.01 e the agency uses the word
sufficient to describe the number of
stamps purchased
um and though this is the same language
that is used in the statute under RSA
541a1
5 the rules are meant to interpret or
make clear the statute so the word
sufficient is a bit vague and should be
clarified further so that the wholesaler
knows exactly how many stamps they need
to keep on hand in order not to be
penalized by the agency
uh the next
comment
um
I believe
I apologize the rest of the comments are
addressed on the agency's conditional
approval request
um
for changes so that's all the comments
staff have at this time
so what do we recommend to do about this
uh I would recommend uh Mr chair that
the committee conditionally approve this
rule with the
um
with an amendment to the already
submitted conditional approval that the
forms that require under pains the
kernel
under the penalties of perjury uh
language be changed as they don't have
the statutory authority to include that
on their forms
um that the form that requires the
statutory language be also amended to
include the affirm
um language in the statute and that's
the agency changed the word sufficient
to be clearer and more defined on what
number of stamps they wholesaler needs
to include under the rules
so we don't see a need for a statutory
change
not your Mr chair
um regarding the perjury issue RSA 641
one through three uh sets penalties for
um making false statements
641-1 is perjury which is a criminal
penalty 641 2 and 3 are less of
penalties they're violations it's been
the long-standing position of Staff in
the committee itself that you cannot use
a rule to impose a criminal criminal
penalty unless you have specific
statutory Authority all right
so I I guess if I may Mr chair
um before I make a motion though could
the department respond to what
um they need to do to address this and
the severity of it I guess thank you
good morning of the Department of
Revenue
so we we did look into this and uh we
did consider the the issues that was
pointed out by uh OLS staff and we do
find that we are operating within the
confines of the statutory language
specifically these uh on the forms and
the forms are exempt from um
541-a requirements this is stated in the
RSA
541-8215 Roman 5 and um in in our dra
statute as well RSA 21
j13-a and just to give some background
on what I found on the uh on the history
legislative history of these statutes so
the exemption of the ra forms from um
the 541a requirement started in
um
in 1996 so that require that statue
enacted in 1996
exams the business profits tax forms bad
forms and IND forms specifically from
the 541a requirement and then 14 years
later in 2010 uh statutory
um legislation expanded that exemption
to all dra forms
um and with that we feel that um
we are still acting within the the
authority of the statute
and also just to add to that dra's
functions and so the array is charged
under
21j12 to oversee the collections of of
state taxes as well as to provide
information collected through Tax
Administration to governor and general
counsel for Public Policy decisions and
it's really imperative that we are able
to really rely on the information that
we receive from from filers that it's
accurate and that that we can be able to
provide this service to to governor and
general counsel
um
and it's also imperative that for us to
be able to rely on that so on the flip
side that the people who are following
this information should be accountable
for that information as well
in terms of the statutory
um
the legislative um Century Authority as
well is that um as mentioned by OLS
staff there's a rc21 j39 2d
the way we read it is that it allows us
to prove to have that level of a
taxation on
on the on all the forms on all our dra
forms
and also their um legislature has also
recognized that that it's important for
us that the level of information that we
provide is accurate so it also
provides the commission with authority
to summon the production of papers and
documents bring into any Tax Matters uh
which the commercial which the
commissioner has authority to
investigate and that's in
21j3 Roman 9.
um and also we will we also
make reference to um
the the criminal and you have your
criminal code AS mentioned by um uh OLS
staff as well
um in regards to why some of the um some
of the statues some of the operating
statutes has specific language for
um
or the pains and pains of penalties of
perjury while some statutes do not
um
I can only submit that it is likely that
um that legislature probably saw that
the inconsistencies in in those
different statutes and might have that
might resolve it through the requirement
to say okay yes allowing the forms to be
governed under the more overarching
umbrella of the 21j statute
and therefore require imposing a more
standardized uh
treatment to all the forms
Mike
um when a court is looking at to
legislative intent uh statutory
construction if they see in some places
where a step where statutes under a
specific chapter authorize perjury and
in other places it does not the court is
going to assume that it was legislative
intent where it did not impose perjury
that that was what the legislature
intended foreign
I think I
um I we rely I'm rely on staff's
comments and uh I'm not at all qualified
to arbitrate this debate in any ways uh
I do recall why this authority to change
forms was given I was here and it was
for expedience purposes
um IRS changes rules and would mandate a
change in your forms and the gel car
process did not afford the dra to be
timely enough in changing the forms to
comply with
I I the chair probably remembers this
but anyways I
I think well I'm not sure what we need I
I would uh
propose a conditional approval based on
um staff comments or maybe an objection
I'm not sure
um what would resolve this but it does
need to be resolved and I would suggest
that the agency submit for statutory
Corrections
um to address this issue and I I
wouldn't see that there would be a lot
of problem in obtaining that just not
very timely so I'm not sure what would
work best and I would just need some
advice on that for maybe staff or where
we are in the time factor for this rule
if there is time allowed to do that am I
clear enough Mr chair and
yeah I concur bill
um
uh if I may Mr chair what the committee
could potentially do is a conditional
approval with the recommendation that
the agency pursue legislative change uh
okay so you you agree with you need a
legislative no um I I think we are able
to
um submit a legislative proposal to to
if that's needed yeah
let's revisit this at the continued
meeting for approval
so we make sure that uh Mr chair the two
proposals that were pushed to the
October 20th meeting are actually the
department of revenues because they are
unavailable to be at the continued
meeting on October 6th okay
so we'll do that do we need
to waive anything to do that
okay
we'll see you again
right just to clarify um is there any
action on our part
between now and the 20th
I think you should be prepared at the
at that meeting to say
you we need to change this
this statute to include the penalty of
perjury for example
and
um what was the
what was the other I remember that that
if we need specific Authority for
perjury then you need to have it every
place that it's applicable what was the
other statutory change
um on one of the forms there's statutory
language that's required in the form to
affirm and so that language needs to be
changed yes either the form or the
statute needs to be changed yeah that
second
um item it mentioned is it's much easier
yes definitely yep
okay and representative hatch has agreed
to be the prime sponsor if if there are
legislative changes needed to be
sponsored thank you
to affect that you would need to contact
me I'm always available I will not
follow up with you until you come to me
with what you need sure so that's clear
thank you thank you
um shall we also address the uh the
issue with the sufficiency language
do you have a response to that yes
um
hang on
the issue with the sufficiency uh
terminology that's used as in the
tobacco tax rule also in the tobacco tax
RSA and that specifically relates to the
sufficiency of stamps text stamps that's
required by the wholesalers so
wholesalers they keep tobacco products
cigarettes and little cigars in various
locations in New Hampshire and it is the
requirement by Statute that the
wholesalers would need to keep maintain
a sufficient amount of stamps to be uh
to be attached to all the tobacco
products
um so that is that terminology of
sufficiency so in from the dra
standpoint we do not know
how many products the um that the
wholesaler would have maintained in each
of these locations and therefore
reading the the language in the rule as
well as the statute they're both
consistent and that requiring that okay
it is the wholesalers who know what is
there we're not requiring them to keep
additional stamps we just require them
to keep the amount of stamps that is
required to be to be attached to all the
products that's available on location
um so um that that's the the use of the
word sufficient
and if I may um this particular language
is already in the existing rule it was
brought up as a staff comment the last
time these rules went through the
process
um and the rule was still adopted with
that language in place um however for
consistency staff felt it should be
brought up again for this committee
okay well
go ahead
I'm sorry to belabor this but to that
end
um could you just say why that word
sufficient we don't like relative terms
and that's a relative term but
I have some understanding in the process
for tax DMS so your wholesaler has
enormous inventory of tobacco products
and would it would it be that it would
be impractical to require them to have
sufficient stance
available on site for all inventory in
place or what is the reason that the
insistence of sufficient is used as
opposed to explicit say as enough stamps
to cover current inventory or something
such as that I mean I I understand the
process and maybe that won't be a
workable thing for wholesalers but could
you just speak to that briefly if that
would be okay Mr chair sure
I think that's
um to your point uh representative I
think that's
achieves the same results
so um I guess
changing the language to to say what you
propose I think that should work for us
okay but just my concern is does that is
that practical that's oh as I would I
would like to understand that uh knowing
someone about the process that how it
works
um I I would my apologies I wouldn't
know whether how practical it is from
the wholesale wholesalers position but
the
you know they they wouldn't know how
many how much products they have in the
warehouse and how much they're planning
to have in the warehouse or wherever
location that they have and they should
according to the statute
um you know they should bake into their
process of ordering the products in to
the state or into the location the same
time obtaining their
the stamps required to attach to all the
products
okay
okay well we shouldn't try to fix this
on the fly so you they're gonna do did I
hear you say Mr chairman that we're
going to cut have a continued meeting
no they'll be at the next break at the
next regular meeting okay so we just
need to work this all out so we're not
doing it on the fly right now we have to
have it specific so that it's workable
okay well thank you
I'm sorry Mr chair if I may just so to
that point when you come back maybe if
and I'm not any way suggesting to tell
you what to do or not to do but I think
I would be a little bit comforted if you
did have a dialogue with the wholesalers
to
um get feedback as to what might be
required and is that practical or not I
I
I would hate to mandate that if it was
totally impractical and I'm not sure it
is or isn't Mr chair I'm sorry they'll
be in touch with you about this thank
you but uh representative um it is a
requirement in the statute so it's not
an additional requirement imposed on the
rule it it's yeah it's not a
okay
thank you thank you
insurance department
both
no let's just gotta deal with it
at a future date
foreign
proceed
thank you Mr chair
so this particular rule
um
the first comment is on page two
it's a note to jail car in that
insurance
350201 A1 B2 has some included language
the language being or any other
valuation mortality table adopted by the
National Association of insurance
commissioner after the 2022 effective
date of this Rule and promulgated by the
rule of the commissioner for this
purpose is not consistent with the rule
that is cited in that particular section
this comment also continues on to
a couple other sections on that page as
well as onto page three where that
language appears in this rule but does
not appear in the rule that is cited uh
therefore the rules are inconsistent and
if these rules were to be adopted the
other rules would have to go through the
rulemaking process to be changed to be
consistent
the
go ahead thank you Mr chair
that
that language is totally unacceptable
because if you're going to have to adopt
it by rule you can change this rule we
we can't
just give them the authority to adopt an
update without a without any kind of
approval
um
it's it's unconstitutional and it's
a concern if they're if they're going to
have to adopt it by rule they can change
change the language to say use this one
we have to be specific in the rules as
to what tables or data we're picking up
from somebody else
and
so I would like to make that point very
strongly
tell us who you are I'm Heather
Silverstein I'm general counsel of the
insurance department and I'm very eager
to address this comment this was not in
our initial proposal this was suggested
by the committee's attorneys to put this
in and so we'd just be as happy it's not
in the model rule as you may remember we
follow the National Association of
insurance Commissioners the model
language that paraphrase is not in the
model we were it was suggested to put it
in and so we did that and then after we
put it in we were told well now you got
to change all your other rules so I
would just be just as we would just as
happy to take that out
it's not in the model it's not needed
and and then the other issue is we do
want to amend our other related rules
before the neic does
because the neic it's a nationwide
process you get input from industry and
consumer groups and whatnot and so the
idea of trying to jam through and
updating all these other rules before
the neic does we are not interested in
that we just want to deal with this
specific Rule and this rule does expire
in October and so it is a rule that we
need for accreditation which is very
important to us so we'd be happy just to
keep it the way the model is which does
not contain that
yes
so the reason that that language was
suggested by staff is because the other
sections in insurance
357.05 a they
some of them referred to the 2022 new
table while these other ones did not so
that was brought up to the agency
as a question and a concern that some of
them were using the updated table and
the other ones were not and that's when
that proposed language was included
just to give that history to the
committee
foreign
so that if I understand you correctly
you would be perfectly happy to put a
period after the 2001 CSO mortality
table yes that's correct
yeah that's like that
thank you
okay
the other comments uh that were on this
particular rule have to do with the
waivers section there was a comment
above that with regard to the
citing of a date of
January
um
yeah I apologize page three of the rule
page six of the packet there was a date
cited to the rule in the rule January
1st 2005 so there was initial comment
put on there with regard to when that
date was actually included in the rules
if it had been after that date it would
have been an authority comment but after
speaking with the agency we are
withdrawing that comment as that date
had been in the rules since 2004 so the
remainder of the comments are on page
three with regard to
the waiver section the first comment uh
is an un
clear comment as the
waiver section does not include how the
how the agency is going to determine how
long a waiver will last
um RSA 541a 22
for states that waivers can only be put
into rule applied if they are
specifically put into rules and a
different additionally they have to be
clear about whether or not a waiver is
going to be temporary if temporary
waivers will be granted there's no
language here providing how long a labor
would last and therefore if temporary
waivers will actually be allowed in this
rule
the other comments with regard to the
section is another unclear comment
um as the rule
Insurance
3500 7.07 A1 specifically
States applying the rule provision would
cause confusion or would be misleading
to Consumers staff had an unclear
comment on that is if a rule is unclear
or confusing to Consumers then the rule
itself
is unclear and therefore should be
addressed by the committee and the final
comment is another unclear comment uh in
insurance
35707 C where the agency's rule requests
a written waiver needs to be made but it
does not state to whom that waiver needs
to be made to
uh and my comments is to the waiver
Provisions this this waiver provision we
started putting in our rules in all of
our rules back around 2016.
um I remember because I was the attorney
that started doing that getting the
rules up to speed part of that process
we engaged jail card Attorneys at that
time when we were developing the
language we also looked to other
agencies that had similar language like
I know Public Utilities Commission has
some very same language actually so we
were trying to be consistent with what
other agencies were doing so that's how
we developed the language it's in about
30 percent of our rules now and it's so
we don't want a situation to happen
where we have to waive a rule we
couldn't waive a rule you don't want the
situation to happen where something
can't be done and you're stuck because
you don't have a waiver in your role
which is exactly why we did it for
history we've had about 10 requests for
waivers since 2018 we we've granted
seven and three of them were withdrawn
if the waiver is not looking great like
if we don't think we're going to Grant
the waiver we usually tell the licensee
it's not looking really good and then
they'll withdraw the waiver so we
publish all of our waivers so everybody
knows if we Grant a waiver for a rule
the reason I'm we've been resistant in
the past because we've had this
objection before as the setting is a
very specific time limit on a waiver
it's because of circumstances change all
the time and we could have a rule that
in fact that's what happened with the
very first waiver that we granted we
could have a rule that is updated and
replaces the need for a waiver so then
you wouldn't obviously want the waiver
to be in place because the rule is is is
going to take over and
um be in effect to handle that very
situation and that was for a new product
because we have new insurance products
all the time and sometimes our rules are
not caught up to the industry and so
that's like a common reason honestly for
this particular rule I highly suspect we
would not use a waiver this is a this is
a rule where we need it for
accreditation it's setting liquid
reserves for life insurance policies so
I don't think that we would use a waiver
in this particular rule however for
consistency and because we never know
what's going to happen we have added it
to this particular role
recommendation from the staff
um at this time there was no conditional
approval request submitted by the agency
so the committee could either approve
this rule as written however it sounds
as though a conditional approval may be
more appropriate to take out that
additional language that was added in
with regard to Insurance five
uh 357.05
um
and or a preliminary objection for the
agency to respond with a objection
response to correct that
I'd like to ask if you would be willing
to
insert in the waiver language
that the request in writing goes to
whomever gets the commissioner or
whomever that
doesn't seem like it would cause any
confusion if
and the other part is that I like the
idea of saying the waiver will be
granted for the duration requested
or or if they're all permanent whatever
the case is but I think it's important
it's important to indicate that you know
if you ask for a waiver sometimes it's
forever and sometimes it's not
so just to be clear we would put that in
a conditional conditional approval get
rid of there's three comments to get rid
of that paraphrase three comments to get
rid of the paraphrase so that the period
goes after CSO mortality table
um
the in writing to the commissioner and
then add the language for the duration
uh requested under the waiver and I
would we would the department would be
agreeable to that
then I move that we request a con
Crete is that in a preliminary objection
so that they can prepare the correction
okay I move a preliminary objection for
that purpose
so my only comment is that this expires
October 1st so I want to make sure that
we are able to get in what we need to
before October 1st however we do the
process
isn't it extended by virtue of your
being in rule making uh that that is
correct because you've started the
rulemaking process the expiration of
those rules will not occur until the new
rules are adopted okay I just want to
clarify
I I appreciate your checking
okay Motion in a second any further
discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
foreign
thank you thank you
charitable trusts
foreign
thank you Mr chair
so the first comment uh with regard to
these rules is on page one it's actually
a note to jail car the Department of
Justice has had the rulemaking authority
regarding charitable trust since
1987 that's an RSA 7 22. this proposal
appears to be the first time that the
agency has done rules for charitable
trust so the committee may have
questions on how the department has been
enforcing uh its current practices
without rules
the
next
comments
a number of these comments have been
addressed in the conditional approval
requests that was submitted by the
department specifically with regard to
the forms there were a number of forms
submitted with this particular rule but
pretty much all of them were addressed
in the conditional approval
request the only ones that are
remaining are
the
ones specifically like the rule we just
discussed uh the waiver section of the
rules had pretty much the same comments
that we just discussed for insurance
there was a provision that um
a waiver may be given to a rule if it is
essentially unclear and there was also
the requirement that a waiver be
submitted in writing however does not
say to whom and finally there is no
uh length of duration for the waiver in
the rules as well
tell us who you are and
good morning Mr chair my name is Diane
Quinlan I'm the director of charitable
trust at the Attorney General's office I
I'd like to begin uh by respectfully
requesting two amendments to our request
for conditional approval I have written
proposals here this morning and I
apologize for the late notice I can
distribute them now or describe them
first
we're not going to take written
comments now all right thank you Mr
chair the first
um uh Amendment would be to eliminate a
couple of uh rules
um that I I don't think
um are uh necessary uh and um
the other is to address the concern
about the waiver we've added language we
propose language that says any person or
entity seeking a waiver shall submit to
the director a written request
specifying the nature and duration of
the waiver sought and so we hope that
that will address the concerns of the
staff
that does address Our concern okay
Mr chair
um is there a deadline on this or we
were to continue this until the next
meeting to have staff have a chance to
review the written changes so we can
address it at the next meeting is that
would happen what's the staffs
um so this language was actually
provided to our office yesterday and so
I did have an opportunity to briefly
review and the changes do address the
remaining staff comments um the only
issue was that a waiver was needed so
the agency had to make an oral request
for a waiver and then additionally with
the deletion of the language
that was something that was new that I
wasn't sure if the committee would have
additional questions on of why that
language was being deleted from The
Proposal so if the committee um
would like to address this at the next
meeting
um then the agency could submit its
proposed changes as an amended
conditional approval and we could
address it again at the next meeting or
um where are you what does
I am as I said uh the amended
conditional approval uh does address all
my comments so I am
the language proposed satisfies this
comments yeah let's not push anything
else off to already so I was going to
make a motion to accept the waiver and
uh have the amended comments added
motion second
by hatch any further discussion
seeing none all those in favor
aye any opposed
motion carries Mr chair I move approval
of the uh amended uh
approval pretty amended request
S
no we have voted to wave
we go to the wave to allow them to put
the amendment in if I'm not mistaken
then just in case any discussion
you've heard the motion in the second
all those in favor
aye any opposed
who seconded that motion sir Brave
Mr chair may I ask a question no
yeah
address the staff
at your convenience
okay
Public Utilities Commission
okay this proposal makes changes to the
municipal and County aggregation rules a
conditional approval request has been
filed and it does eliminate all staff
comments so I have no comments this was
not placed on your consent agenda
because there has been testimony that
testimony has generally been favorable
and it looks like that there is also one
informational note to bring to your
attention in the proposal and this is on
page eight of the PDF
it's also page eight of the conditional
approval request
so there was some legislation that came
through last session SB 265 it is
effective as of July 25th 26 this year
it is included in your attachments so
just pointing out to you that the
language that is um the highlighted
language there has been submitted to to
deal with that legislation like I said
um there's probably some folks here
looking to testify so those were all my
comments
okay
tell us who you are
my name is Eric wind I'm an attorney
advisor for the Public Utilities
Commission and I'd be happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have questions from the committee
and Cliff and Company are you objecting
to this rule
motion by McGuire second by hatch
any discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
thank you
Department of Safety yeah yes sir so um
we realized this morning that uh there
is one document that is missing from
your
um your uh in your attachments
which is the little and it looks like
you should already have a hard copy of
that document it was the agency's cover
letter letter to the preliminary
objection response
so these are the safety ignition lock
program rules at the July 21st meeting
the committee voted to enter a
preliminary objection to these rules
based on its determination that the
department doesn't have either federal
or state authority to have the interlock
devices set at an alcohol alcohol set
point of .020
RSA 265 a37 establishes the alcohol
concentration level that results in a
violation but the statute doesn't say
what that set point should be you know
the Baseline if you will
RSA
25943 a in its definition for ignition
interlock device says that the device
prevents the vehicle from starting
unless the person provides a breath
sample with a concentration of alcohol
that is below a preset level but again
the statute doesn't say what that preset
level is
um a testimony from the Department
indicated that .020 is an industry
standard there was some testimony from
the industry that initially
um wanted that set point changed I think
from the last meeting
um the department had um testified to
the um to the fact that the the industry
was okay with that set point level the
department also stressed that there are
two types of drivers the over 21 and
under 21 and so that does impact that as
well
but again
um the you have the preliminary
objection response in front of you and
the agency's cover letter and they've
made no changes
um as a result of um any of the the back
and forth testimony that we've had in
previously so with that that's all I had
to say on this proposal
good morning
turn your mic on
March montani for the Department of
Safety Chief legal counsel I've got with
me deputy director of the DMV Michael
Todd I've got
um financial responsibility supervisor
uh Bob Keller and also Captain Chris
feder from the state police I know that
in our multiple meetings about these
rules there have been several questions
from enforcement to
the actual program I think one of the
we're just here to answer any questions
you may have one of the outstanding
questions that representative McGuire
had that I couldn't answer was the was
it the deviation for the device and
we've since learned it's .005
or we want to share that rather sorry
thank you questions from the committee
foreign
the last time was that there seems to be
an industry standard uh but there was a
conflict between uh the the practice of
using this device between uh what is the
the warning
and so forth I don't have to go through
the whole discussion we all remember
that uh and how have you resolved it so
that we have something that both
complies with the industry standard but
also does not put the uh
public in Jeopardy in advance of what
where the actual statutory red line is
so the
the we haven't
the I think that what the DMV will say
is that the industry standard and the
testimony or the written testimony
provided by the industry was the
recommendation to have an alcohol set
point of 0.020 and the and to
distinguish that from the violation
which isn't in statute but even in the
violation what the statute says is that
point anything greater than 0.025 is a
violation it doesn't say that that's the
preset level
of the device
Tim
so well I'm trying to understand we have
a statutory requirement that basically
you're you're against the you violate
the law if you have a 0.025 and you
attempt to use the interlock device is
that correct over 0.025 point over 0.025
however the state by installing the
Interlock system and setting a set point
of the point zero two zero
is taking action against an individual
that hasn't violated law by not letting
them start their car and get to wherever
they're going so I'm trying to
understand where the authority is to
allow them not to take not to act when
the statutory authorities of 0.025 or
greater
so the authority is that in the
definition of an ignition interlock
device the device is set to have a
preset level that's going to stop the
car from
starting
it's it's not a violation at a 0.020
representative Lang and committee
members if I may uh Mike Mike Todd and
the deputy director for the Division of
Motor Vehicles and the
I understand the concern that's being
raised and I'd just like to to um
provide a comment on on what the public
policy
um implications are the original the
intention of the program is behavior
modification the intention of the
program is to modify behavior of someone
who's shown poor judgment and when they
are consuming alcohol and making the
decision to drive or not to drive
the intention of the program is to to
help them develop that better behavior
and if they do not participate in many
if not most cases if the individual is
not participating in the program they
would not be able to drive at all per
the court order
so the reason the set level is at 0.020
is because it gives them an opportunity
to learn to make better choices to have
better judgment without incurring that
violation that they wouldn't incur that
they were above 0.025 the goal is to
help people get back on their feet get
back into making that those responsible
judgments so they can drive without
concern for Public Safety and that
that's the public policy of uh intent of
this of this program
and and that's I don't have anything
else any questions
Senator Gray
uh I just have a comment on the
statement that would be a perfect
statement if we were here you know
sitting as a body looking at changing
statute
but right now the statute says one thing
the rule says another thing
and I can't vote for it okay
thank you
Mr chair I think they are within the
statue as it was read and if we have
concerns with that it's up to the person
that has the concern to change the
statute because again this is where I
have this thing about relative terms or
not being explicit the statue is not
explicit that's our bad
um so I think they're within their realm
of authority and I would uh propose an
approval thank you Mr chair
well so I guess Mr I'm struggling with
the idea that
it'd be like stopping a car out we have
a 70 mile an hour speed limit but we
stop them at 60 because we were worried
that they might go over 70. and
they have no authority to do that right
because they're within the law so my
concern is that we'd be approving
something just to that effect is where
well I don't know anybody going over 70
nor do I want anybody try drinking while
driving we have statutory Authority
that's set and we're setting a lower
standard by rules which I don't think
would be allowed
I understand the concern and I do not
disagree with it but our job here is not
to legislate
our job in gel car is to assure that the
legislative intent is followed and the
intent is in the written word and
there's not a defined limit
um so they're within what we legislated
so if we want to change that we have to
do a legislative change that's why I
proposed an approval thank you Mr chair
yes thank you I agree with
representative Lang that this imposes a
for whatever good reason it may be it
imposes a restriction on people that is
beyond the statutory limit
it may be good you know good training
and all that but it's
if you're at .020 or 0.0201 you're you
are not committing a crime
and you should not be penalized by not
being able to drive
under the authority of of the crime if
you're talking about could be you know
creating good habits and all that yes
but I don't think that's that's a pro
if I may Mr chair it was pointed out and
I hate to belabor this oh I'm sorry
uh thank you thank you Mr chairman so
um representative McGuire they have
they've already been conv these
individuals have already been convicted
of a crime
that's why that's why they're required
to participate in the program if they
choose not to participate in the program
they they don't drive they're not able
to drive at all and so because they're
already suspended this program allows
them to actually transport themselves
where if the program didn't exist they
would not be able to do so so I think
it's I I
I just want to encourage the committee
to to understand that that they're
already suspended these individuals
already have a suspended driving
privilege we're not removing a privilege
that they've been they've that's been
restored
this program is giving them the
opportunity to get back on their feet
thank you
again Mr chair
I I don't object to the program my my
objection is that the statutory
Authority that we set for the program is
a 0.025 and we're at a different stats
there setting conditions below that stat
that statutory requirement so I I'm just
struggling with the idea of we're
imposing a rule that uh or we're setting
a new term and condition of a violation
even if you're not being charged
criminally or or in court you're going
to be you'll be uh
it's just a different rule than what we
set in statute which is a .025 and we're
penalizing somebody below that level
I'll go back to my example of a speeding
ticket we're stopping somebody for 60 in
a 70 Zone when they didn't break the law
may I respond thank you Mr chairman so
representative Lang I I just again I
would
I would like to
discuss that these individuals they have
broken the law that's they've been
convicted of breaking the law in the in
the example you gave this is a person
who would have who would have a proven
track record of speeding
breaking breaking the speed limit and
it's a danger to themselves and to other
people on the road and the program
exists to change that behavior and so
what what this allows them to do is to
change the behavior and learn that new
judgment without violating without
incurring a new violation
that and we believe that that is what is
safest for uh for the individuals who
are on the road the children the women
the mothers the daughters the wives the
husbands who are out on the road
to help change that behavior
and that's that's what the uh the prior
legislative intent was that's what the
Nitza standard Vanessa's suggestion is
and and that's what we're trying to do
here
thank you
yes I move we approve the rule
or the the uh
objection response and with the requests
that the department seeks statutory
Authority for their 0.020 set point
we we would be very happy to do that
thank you very much representative
Maguire
motion by McGuire second by hatch
discussion
I guess this
figure out how to go forward Mr chair
yeah
going with a roll call vote
Senator gray no
another Apprentice yes Senator Ward
the chair of votes yes
representative McGuire
representative hatch yes representative
Schmidt yes
representative Lang no
representative verse no
representative yes
did somebody write down
six to four with six six to four
approval
okay motions approved
thank you very much committee Department
of Health and Human Services
yes sir
um before we get into the proposal the
agency has late filed a conditional
approval request
so if we could get the committee first
to a vote to accept that late filing
then we'll
um jump into the
proposal
I have a motion
by McGuire's second by hatch all those
in favor
any opposed
okay so
um uh this proposal it makes changes for
the process for involuntary emergency
admission like I said the agency has
filed a conditional approval request but
there's still um quite a lot of
substantive substantive issues that
remain some of them may need legislation
to address
the emergency rules have expired they
expired just a few days ago the final
proposal was filed for the August
meeting however due to multiple OLS
staff illnesses The Proposal was
postponed to this meeting and the rules
subsequently have expired for a few days
the committee may have some questions
about that
that is a way of background in May of
last year the Supreme Court issued an
opinion
for a court case of Jane Doe versus
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services in Merrimack Court
and the court analyzed several statutes
135 C 31 and the bottom line held that a
person is entitled to a probable cause
hearing within three days of the
completion of a certificate not the
person's delivery to the designated
receiving facility or the completion of
the petition there's some ongoing
litigation and potentially there'll be
some legislative changes this session so
the department is probably going to be
in rule making several times
um I think the main comment that I have
without going through all of the
comments is that the proposal doesn't
accurately use the terms petition and
certificate and that is problematic
because they don't represent the same
thing if you look at the judiciary's
form on the first page of the
instructions to the petitioner it lays
out what all the elements are for the
form what represents the petition what
represents the certificate what
represents the witness statements and
then the physical and mental evaluation
the results of those
the um according to the statute the
three-day clock for the probable cause
hearing attaches upon the completion of
the certificate and not petition
and then the mental and physical health
evaluations must occur either
simultaneously as the petition or must
occur within three days prior to the
completion of the certificate so it's
kind of very important to make sure that
that is laid out correctly in the rule
right now the rule is sort of ambiguous
at times it's referring to the petition
and certificate when it means just the
form all you know the form in its
entirety other times it's referring to
it when it really means either the
petition or the certificate so that's
like my overall
concern with the rule
as I said
um there's a lot of going on
um Chief legal counsel isn't present
today so I'm unsure of how much we can
actually get through with all the
comments
but um that's a high level overview
there's also um going to be quite a few
people probably here uh to submit some
testimony testimony has been linked and
you should have it from
Naomi from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association and from the ACLU and with
that I'll um turn it over
go ahead
good morning Allison radmay
administrator of the administrative
rules unit here for the Department of
Health and Human Services
um I do want to touch on the
interchanging petition certificate
um language we did in our conditional
approval
Define petition and certificate we did
add that in as the whole form provided
by the court which is entitled as a
whole petition and certificate for
involuntary emergency admission there's
various breakdowns within the form but
as a whole it is the petition
certificate that is now defined and
outlined accordingly throughout what
pages need to be used for what in the
role
um and then just kind of going on
um ATM 614 was created to identify and
address uh the process to ensure those
who are determined to need an
involuntary emergency admission from a
certifying provider uh that they receive
probable cause hearing by the courts to
determine whether the Ia is appropriate
uh within three days of the completion
of the petition certificate
um this this rule is important for
several reasons uh to get it on the
books um we do understand that it is not
perfect
um but we are willing to work and we
plan on working with our stakeholders
moving it Forward at this point as you
know this was an emergency rule that the
department had filed in March of 2022 we
did intend to have it heard at the
August gel car we will receive comments
back on this from attorney staff on
Friday this past Friday and we tried to
turn around some changes as quickly as
possible again we know this is an
ongoing
working session that needs to happen
behind the scenes with our partners and
stakeholders and we are willing to do
that um but we do hope that we can get
something on the books that we have to
work on so we go without or so we do not
go without any rule
at this time
thank you and uh
good morning I'm attorney Steve vonker
Council for New Hampshire hospital
okay
so
um I mean there are a few options
um the rules have expired so
um I think probably from a practical
standpoint if this isn't approved the
agency might be faced with doing an
emergency rule again so that they can
have something in you know in effective
they can do that as long as it's not the
same emergency rule as what just was
filed and expired you could preliminary
object and give them time to work
through this proposal but again the
rules are expired so they're you know
they're operating without rules at this
point you may have some questions about
that you could conditionally approve
um I think those are your options right
now so what point are you in your
discussions and you're working on
making this a better role
um I think I apologies
um it's continuous at this point like I
said we received comments continue over
a year or a day or you know oh no we're
ready to immediately go back into
rulemaking and start working with our
stakeholders like I said we understand
Monday
happy to start working yes okay
because I mean it's expired because
nothing was happening right so yes we
understand this expired and nothing has
happened within those four days and
depending on the outcome today is how we
would have
okay yes
I have one card from
Ms thundberg who wishes to speak
so let's let her
hear what she has to say on behalf of
the hospital Association
for the record my name is Kathy Bizarro
thundberg Executive Vice President New
Hampshire Hospital Association you do
have a copy of our testimony for this
Committee in your packet I just want to
speak briefly to some of the high points
I'm not going to go over the nine pages
that I submitted Our Testimony is really
centered around the universal fact that
patients who are deemed to be a harm to
themselves or others should be afforded
the protections of the state's mental
health system through the iea process
having clear and transparent rules for
ieas is utmost importance because
um they there really hasn't been any in
place so I agree with the Department
that it's important to have these rules
in place however the rules as written
and presented to you are inconsistent
and contrary to current state law
particularly RSA
135c29i which says that upon completion
of an iea certificate the patient must
be immediately transferred to a
designated receiving facility or New
Hampshire hospital in addition as noted
by the council for gel car both the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and U.S District
Court for the District of New Hampshire
both have held that involuntary
emergency admissions occur when the iea
certificate is completed and upon
completion the patient must be
immediately transferred unfortunately
there's many areas in the rule that is
contrary to that in particular the
um there's just like one one example one
section that it references physical
exams to be completed within three days
and mental health exams to be completed
within three days
fortunately the the certificate has to
be signed with those two exams completed
so the rules are kind of contrary saying
that the exams can happen you know
within three days but yet the
certificate has to be completed with
that done so that needs to be cleaned up
that's just one example okay so your
recommendation so that we can accept
this rule would be to do what uh
unfortunately we do object to the rules
as they're drafted
um I I don't know I guess it would be up
to the jail Care Council to be able to
tell you what to do as far as how okay
so you object to the rule yeah okay
thank you chill
foreign
on behalf of the ACLU of New Hampshire
I'm a legal director there I'm also here
on behalf of the class plaintiffs um in
a lawsuit that was filed with respect to
the due process rights of individuals
who are involuntarily detained certainly
the uh the rules here are better than
the process that existed for the the
past decade but we still do have some
concerns with respect to the draft I
haven't seen what was filed uh
conditionally on on Friday
but do you you know want to thank DHHS
though some of our feedback during the
process over July was accepted but
there's still some concerns principally
actually for the reason that committee
Council raised with respect to the
conflation between petition and
certificate which seems like technical
why would that matter and it actually
really matters with respect to timing
because timing here is critical for
individuals who are being involuntarily
detained they're entitled to prompt due
process and so those terminology issues
potentially in our view if not clarified
could the rules could then be construed
to possibly extend for three additional
days in voluntary detention I won't get
into the weeds of why that's the case
it's drawn out explained in our
testimony
um and the last couple things I'll say I
won't get into the weeds we do have some
additional recommendations we think that
would make the rules better more
consistent with providing due process
rights for the individuals who are here
because really at its core what we're
dealing with are individuals who may may
not be going through crisis who are
being detained against their will and in
our view it's absolutely critical that
they receive all the due process
protections that they're entitled to and
so we list those out which would include
providing some Protections in the event
that there's decision of an iea
certificate it would also provide some
protections with respect to the venue of
due process hearings as to where
they occur and making sure there's
clarity as to who is required to
actually file the petition so we would
just recommend some further work with
respect to these these rules we're happy
to be part of that process and provided
comment back in July thank DHHS for its
work and and we'll I'm happy to again to
continue with the process thank you
any questions from the committee Bill
thank you Mr chair was these concerns
presented to the department during the
public hearing process of the roommate
keep yes they were uh with Pro with one
clarification uh section three
um in our testimony which has to do with
the
uh rescissions I don't think we
um
it's either section three or section
four that we have subsequently added I
don't remember which I could let you
know if that's okay most of it was
presented earlier yes
thank you
yes do you have a recommendation for
what we should do
because do you want to have no rules at
all do you want us to adopt these rules
however
faulty they may be that that's a hard
question
um I I think
with respect to the definitional
problems petition certificate I
that just needs to be fixed in in my
view
um I don't know that I wholesale object
to the rules because again I think on
balance this is better than what we
didn't have anything before so that is
something that I'm I'm kind of
struggling with to to be honest I'm
sorry I don't have a direct answer
that's probably the best I can do at the
moment
can we expect something by our continued
meeting
um I would have to touch base with uh
Chief legal officer things here once she
gets back from traveling to travel for
work right now
um but once she gets back into the
office
could I also be cleared I'm sorry Mr
chairman I don't want to interrupt I I
am strictly basing my testimony on the
the version from July 26th I do not know
whether in the subsequent filing changes
were made consistent with our public
comment so I just wanted to make that
abundantly clear I have not seen any new
version so
I can get a conditional approval
um request copy out to the stakeholders
so it's certainly possible that perhaps
some of these issues were rectified I I
just I haven't seen it I'm sorry
is that conditional approval request on
the it is linked yes you do have it yes
ma'am it is on on the teleport packets
website oh I I apologize I I can't read
16 people I'm sorry my testimony is to
be abundantly clear based on the July 26
version
um so
um I just want to clarify that I'm sorry
so for patients now
this what we have
grants them protection
yes I think that's right I you know I it
provides currently the prac unlike what
was happening before it seems that due
process hearings are actually now being
provided in in some instances even when
individuals are in emergency rooms which
was not happening before due process was
provided once they went to the
designated receiving facility often New
Hampshire hospital but because of the
wait list that could have been weeks at
a time
um so so there are hearings happening
now actually I'm not going to get into
the details of this but I have to be
clear for the record that we actually
don't think the way these hearings are
currently conducted are fully consistent
with due process they're telephonic so
the courts can't meaningfully in our
view engage with the patients this this
rule is not really addressing that
though right it's just addressing when
these hearings occur so to answer your
question more directly there are
hearings happening now they weren't
happening before we have separate
concerns that will raise it another
another forum
with that understanding I would like to
move we accept the conditional approval
response with the additional
consideration that the department enter
into rule making immediately to clear up
the distinction between the petition and
the certificate
further comments
discussion
machine
that's what we're hoping
yeah
the party you're going back to work on
Monday we're going back to work on
Monday okay
saying no other discussion all this in
favor
aye opposed
immunization registry registry rules
foreign
good morning
thank you
um so this proposal is an interim rule
2022-5
um
submitted by the department and has to
do with the immunization
exemption
um
for schools based on religious reason as
well as the process for withdrawal from
the immunization registry
this interim rule comes
from two changes to the statute
um one was HB
1035 which was chaptered as
well 55 and the laws of 2022.
this particular change in the statute
removed the requirement that a exemption
for religious reasons to a school be
notarized
the proposed rule does remove that
requirement that notarization
requirement for religious exemption
and then the second
statute
Amendment comes from HB
1487 which is chapter 307 of the laws of
2022 that particular
um change in the statute
requires that a patient or a patient's
Guardian if the patient is a minor May
withdraw from participation in the
immunization registry by either having a
health care provider sign off on the
form or for the form to be notarized
that was also
uh changed in the rule and then with
regard to staff comments we did have a
couple unclear legislative intent
comments however the agency did submit a
conditional approval request which
addressed all of the staff comments so
the only remaining uh
addressed those unclear legislative
intent comments the remaining staff
comments are all notes to jail car for
um pointing out the changes the
statutory changes as well as pointing
out to the committee that pursuant to
RSA 141 C
all right
to the commissioner does have the
authority to design the content of all
forms via the RSA 541a process as the
rules do include some language that is
included on their forms um specifically
regarding
HP 301.13 which is the exemption form
they include the language
discussing the risks of
required vaccinations
um that they may change their decision
and
submit evidence of vaccination to the
school at any time as well as advising
not in the event of an outbreak of
vaccine preventable of a vaccine
preventable Disease an exempt student
shall be excluded from School attendance
in accordance with RSA
141c20d which is what the statutory
language is
um
and additionally with regard to the
withdrawal from the registry once again
the commissioner does have the ability
to design that form and has included the
language that is on the form in the rule
um
so at this time once again the
committee's three options are to approve
the rule uh conditionally approve the
rule if
the committee feels additional changes
are made
or to do a preliminary objection though
as I stated at this time staff doesn't
have any substantive comments
thank you before the department answers
the staff's comments I would like you to
address the issue of your having posted
two versions of this form on your
website without any approval which is
definitely beyond your scope of
authority would you could you explain
that
thank you for the question
representative McGuire in order to be oh
sorry my name is Abby Rogers I'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health Services uh
in regard to the form the form was
redesigned as a result of HB 1035 being
signed into law the effective data that
legislation was July 19th the department
felt that um you know we had there were
many vaccine related bills over the
course of the session and really wanted
to be very responsive to having a
ability for people who wanted to have
choose to have a religious exemption for
their child have us form available
before the start of the school year so
we updated the form and posted it not as
a required form but as a suggested form
and realized that uh you know we may
have jumped the gun a little bit by
posting it without having the form
reviewed by gel car so that that was why
the form was posted and then we did take
that down and now we're here to go
through the process and have that I
understand there's a different version
of it post it again
there is a form posted right now we
heard there were concerns about certain
parts of this form that we're here to
discuss today and suggest and have a
very basic form for parents to access
which uh they can use if they want if
they would like to submit that to the
school otherwise they can you know use a
letter as well
Madam chair if I make yes absolutely
thank you um 1035 was my bill so
um
I want to be clear so we we put up a
form against 540 that was a violation of
541. we took that form down then we put
up another form knowing that we're still
invite one was dated in July now we have
another one dated in in August and
before us we have another form dated in
September
um and and I guess my my question is
how did that happen when I asked when we
asked earlier last month I mean I'm
concerned because this bill was signed
into law in May so we had plenty of time
either for some sort of interim rule or
anything else and nothing was done
um it was signed into law it was passed
by the by the legislature weeks before
that so you knew it was coming and no
rule making no interim rulemaking
nothing was done we just outright
violated 541a by posting requirements
and I'm just concerned by that and where
else that might be occurring he also
didn't even bother to try an expedited
revision to forms which is a process for
updating a form in in some cases and so
you're you're confusing
you're confusing people who are looking
for it on your website because that is
whether you say it's a suggestion or not
it's assumed to be required
since this vaccinations are required
and you have you're you're changing it
without any oversight or any Authority
and I am extremely disappointed that a
major department like HHS doesn't
understand that a form has the force and
effect of law
and people will obey it whether it's
correct or not and whether or not it's
you've made changes to it without any
oversight I'm
severely concerned about that
um thank you for that um I we appreciate
that and
um again we had many pieces of
legislation that were going uh through
rulemaking in regard to vaccination
1487 and also HB 1035 we also have HB
1606 which also is also representative
blank's bill which has an effective date
of uh July 1st 2023 those are all three
related to withdrawal of the vaccine
registry we had looked at those
holistically and trying to move those
forward we wanted to move these two
forward and interim rule again the form
was posted and again we weren't trying
to undermine anyone's Authority we were
in hindsight looking to try to make it
easier for those folks to to use that
form to exempt their children if they
chose to using the religious exemption
form so we're here today to talk about
um uh the forms that we have put forward
we hope that we could discuss those and
take a look at those thank you
one last comment Madam chair yes sir I
heard something I want to be clear So
currently it's DHHS position that the
current Forum which is dated August 22
that's currently on your webs uh yeah I
think that's obviously that's not been
approved well I understand that I
understand but I'm just trying to
clarify something they said that to make
sure I understood it right use the
current form that is up there you're
saying there's a suggestion not a
requirement that parents can write their
own and that's completely legal and
completely okay
hello my name is Anne-Marie recuri I'm
the immunization section chief so prior
to this proposed act to put the form
into administrative rule the form has
not been part of administrative rule
um so the department felt as though it
was the the best option to be able to
Simply take the old form that was
original and remove that notary
requirement so we removed that notary
signature line and that's the current
form that you see posted on the website
foreign
I'm not sure if they have more they want
to say before I have some more questions
so yes give them the opportunity to
speak because we kind of jumped right in
hello Allison uh radmay sorry
um administrator of the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services and
um we are here again to move these uh
these new forms forward I did want to
just touch base really quick on the
expedited process versus the intramural
process we decided to do the interim
rule process opposed to the expedited
form process because these new forms
with removing the notary requirement
that was actually listed in our rule
um and that's something that we can't
change in that process so we moved it
forward in this way instead but with
that we will open to any questions that
you may have
oh absolutely thank you
um so I'm looking at as part of our
packet we were given um the old version
of 141c uh 20-c which is the exemption
language
um and under Exempted language too which
deals with the religious exemption that
statute specifically says apparent
illegal Garden objective immunization
because if religious beliefs the paranor
legal guardian shall sign and we've
struck the word a note a notarized uh
shall sign a form stating that child has
not been immunized because of religious
beliefs so that's the statute as it
exists I believe as it's been modified
and we agreement with that that's the
statute great so as I look at that and
then I look at your new form and I look
at your new rule my question comes down
within your right in your opening line
in section e in accordance with RSA 141
C colon 20 C which is the exemption
statute admitting official which I
assume mean is a school shall exempt a
child from a immunity immunization
requirement but then you go on and say
only if and you start adding new
conditions for a religious exemption in
saying that they have to acknowledge
risk they have to acknowledge disease
vaccines prevent disease they have to
acknowledge the transmission disease
none of which is in the statute and
which is is a condition of religious
exemption requirement
I'll go on further and say that addition
on the new form that you're proposing
you now require parents again because
they're required to submit this form
you're requiring parents to disclose
medical information to you again not
required by Statute anywhere in the
immunization in the exemption statute
you're asking them that which ones do
you have and which ones you are claiming
the exemption for again not authorized
statute anywhere that I can see that you
start collecting another database that
has immunizations in it
um
so I I'm concerned about those issues
that we're setting new requirements that
aren't authorized by law in order in
order to Grant a religious exemption
um and then additionally as I look
through this rule I'm concerned as we
get down on page two and we're looking
at that second line where it says I
understand that is my responsibility to
inform my health care providers of any
decision to withdraw from the registry
so that no future immunizations
vaccination information reported the
DHHS and yet the legislative intent was
clear in 1606 and while I understand
that hasn't gone into into statute the
legislation is extremely clear when it
says that no patient or personal data
such as name address date of birth
immunization or vaccine information
shall be entered into the registry
without explicit written or electronic
consent from the patient does it put an
obligation on the patient to go tell the
provider I don't want this what it makes
the obligation is that the state has a
requirement to make sure that it has
some sort of consent to take the data
so I'm concerned now that we're putting
we're shifting
uh the the legislative intent was clear
in 1606 the obligation is that you have
permission to take the data and now
we're pushing the obligation back on the
patient which is not the legislative
intent and what our legislation our
legislature believes so I'm really
concerned that again we're collecting
Medical Data that's not authorized that
would be in violation of our
constitution where we're collecting data
without consent in the patient and they
can't they're forced to give consents
coercion we force them into given
consent otherwise the kid can't go to
school unless they fill out this form
giving medical data so I'm really
concerned by this rule that it violates
all kinds of a practice and B so my my
question is how do we get past that what
is the how what is your authority to set
a new standard what is your Authority
now to shift the consent back to the
patient instead of the state who has the
obligation to collect the data to have
consent to collect data
representative Lang um I think I could
shed a little bit of light on why some
of these things were included in the
suggested form uh that you have here
today for the religious exemption
um the uh listing of of the
immunizations that the parent or or
Guardian is suggesting that they would
like to exempt their child from first of
all to be clear that in this form would
goes to the school nurse this does not
come back to the department this is a
department form that would be used for
the parent it would go to the school
nurse so these this list of vaccinations
is for the use of the school nurse
um if there is some some parents opt to
opt out from all vaccines for religious
exemption others might just pick one for
a specific reason the school nurse is
the person who is in charge of making
sure that the school Community is
healthy if there should be an outfit an
outbreak of
communicable disease that's preventable
by immunization per requirement and a
child is is exempt and there's an
outbreak it's for that child's safety
that the school nurse know which
which vaccination that child does not
have in case there is an outbreak I
think it was mentioned before that under
RSA 141c20d if there is an outbreak and
a child is not vaccinated due to
religious reasons or perhaps medical
reasons they would be exempt from school
for for their safety that's why that was
included there many states do opt to
have that as a listing to help the
school identify if in in the case of an
outbreak so that's that's the kind of
rationale for for adding that
um I would say that the the additional
questions on the bottom of the form is I
understand the risk of Contracting the
disease um you know those those
questions are you know those are public
health
um uh Public Health statements that help
someone who is opting you know their
right to opt out for a religious
exemption to just be reminded why
vaccine and vaccination is important for
community in school and why there are
some students at school that cannot have
vaccine due to
um neurological conditions due to
immunocompromised diseases and so this
is just reminding reminding folks that
um you know there are other popular
other people in the school that that may
benefit from people being vaccinated
certainly you're right not not to have
your child vaccinated but as a reminder
for the broader Community perspective
for public health and that's why those
things were included on this form and I
can
um I you know 1606 I know is is becoming
effective July 1st 2023 we have done
some initial meetings internally with
the department and with stakeholders to
go over the language for those potential
rules um and we are not too far along
with that yet but certainly those
concerns you express about collecting
data and how this is written it
certainly is is very very valuable
feedback as we continue with that
process
um and you know I and for example you
know if we if I could share a little bit
just about your question about 1487
um about uh I understand the withdrawal
from the participation in the registry
uh all of those so I understand section
of the form if you will so previous to
uh the statute change in HP 1487
previously to that bill passing and
becoming effective to withdraw from the
registry a patient or a patient's local
Guardian if the patient was a minor
would need a healthcare provider
signature that bill removed that bill
has changed the statute so now you can
have a health care provider if you
choose to sign your form or you can have
a notary these questions we feel if
you're going the notary route would not
be something that usually if you would
go to a healthcare provider they would
go on over this with you as an
educational piece before you withdrew
your information these were included in
the form primarily too if you choose the
notary option then you have that little
piece of Education
um that that you wouldn't get if you had
an opportunity to speak with your
healthcare provider about withdrawal so
I hope I was able to answer some of
those questions for you
any other questions from the committee
so man if I may ma'am one more question
please absolutely I I I just I I'm
trying to
um again understand the statutory
authorization to include new conditions
because again my concern I'll be honest
with them I'm pretty sure I'm okay with
the new form you just put up that stated
August 22. I would have no objection to
that that form it's a clean simple form
that removes the notor requirement that
just says I'm requesting a religious
exemption I'm done and that's it it's
the collection of the new data that I'm
trying to understand where the authority
comes from again that doesn't doesn't
exist in statute right under under that
20c
um uh statute doesn't have an obligation
to acknowledge any of this it just
strictly says that you request one and
so I guess I'd have no objection if you
were being present bringing forward that
stats that's that form you just put on
the website yesterday or whatever it was
um but this other data I'm still trying
to struggle with I understand the public
health concern that you may have but
we're collecting data and whether it's
you or the school that's still the
government that's still state agencies
requiring data and I don't I don't get
where we have that authority to require
the citizen provide that data not by
Statute so representative Lang the last
paragraph
which says that in the outbreak of
vaccine preventable disease exempt
student the shall be excluded from
School attendance and if that's
specifically in statute so they need to
know that you have not received
the measles vaccine in case there's a
measles outbreak and then they do not
allow you to attend school so again that
is specifically in RSA 141 c20d
understood Madam chair and that's why I
like this is the new form they just
posted yesterday
um and the new form is very clean it's
it's again this is the whole form as
compared to this one right simple little
statement and paragraph a comment and on
the new form it says it has that warning
it just says the administration
immunization agents conflicts of my
religious beliefs with the religious
beliefs of the paralegal Garden is
student listed above I understand that
in the event of an outbreak the vaccine
preventable disease in my child's school
um or Child Care Facilities State Health
director May exclude my child from the
school or Healthcare facility at their
own for their own protection this
exclusion will last into the incubation
period from the last identified case of
the Pinnacle diseases past so that's
informational right you're no you're
notifying this one
as far as I'm concerned especially as a
former prosecutor has potential for some
overzealous prosecutor to go after a
parent because you're forcing a parent
to acknowledge uh that you put your
child at risk
um and and and I and I could easily see
a potential overzealous prosecutor when
your child gets the measles deciding to
charge you with neglect because you were
warned that this could happen and you
did it anyway and your child's now sick
so I I I again I completely I'm okay
with this form
um that they just posted which is
informational and tells warns the
parents that if you choose to do this
your child may be excluded from school
the other one I'm not I I think is it
causes is problematic in forcing our our
parents to uh to to provide a
information they may not want to provide
and you don't have a choice thank you
do you have a further comment yes ma'am
thank you
um I do want to say
um that basic language that is on that
new form that was posted yesterday
um that was one of the legislative
intent comments that were provided by
OLS um for us to change that made to
shall sell these children shall be
exempts
um or excluded from school
um so that actually was changed within
the rule text and OLS staff did point
out
um their third comment uh first on the
left that pursuant to RSA
141-c Roman 2 the commissioner has
authority to design the content of all
forms via RSA 541a process with respect
to these issues and that's where you
have these understandings coming in on
these new forms
yes okay so if you have the authority to
include that we have the authority to
object to it correct you can only adopt
that if it is approved by the committee
correct and I was just pointing out that
we did have the authority to thank you
and I'm sorry I just want to
um edit that it's
rsa141c6 Roman numeral two the six was
admitted from the comment so I just
wanted to make clear that that is the
statute that they're referring to and
yes it does say that the commissioner
has the ability to design the content of
all forms required for reporting
communical diseases and I also wanted to
point out that
RSA
141c4 the duties of the commissioner the
commissioner shell in
um paragraph three
um
I apologize hold on I
that you know they have the duties to
establish maintain suspend isolation and
quarantine to prevent the spread of
communicable diseases once again tying
into that RSA 141c
um
D
um in exempting chill or refuse um
having students not come to school if
there is an outbreak of a certain
disease that they're not vaccinated for
um
so I just wanted to bring that to the
committee's attention as well and also
in RSA 141c4 in paragraph seven the
commissioner has a duty to educate the
public relative to the cause prevention
and treatment of communicable disease
and relative to the precisions of this
chapter and its rules regarding
reporting investigation examination
treatment and care
thank you attorney Morrow
um three points regarding the May versus
shell issue staff did raise the point
that the rule said may but statute
specifically says it shall be the
students shall be uh prevented from
attending
um
regarding representative blank's
comments about 1606 I would agree to the
extent that yes the Department's
absolutely going to need to go through
rulemaking to make accommodations for
the requirements of that bill however
this interim rule is only in effect for
180 days and 1606 doesn't take effect
until next July so the department would
have time to adjust for 1606 and could
in fact go through the whole rulemaking
process and have the rule ready on the
same date that 1606 goes into place in
fact they they need to go through the
whole okay and and lastly regarding the
extra information that's now in the form
and in the rule regarding I understand I
understand uh House Bill 1487 has fairly
specific language about requiring
acknowledgments by the parents
okay thank you thank you
oh I just had a quick comment to make on
1606 there's no even though it's not
effective until next year there's no
retroactive requirement that the
department remove the data the personal
data that's already in the registry I
just wanted right
okay that's the I guess I just have a
question about
does does the agency have the right to
add add and access for staff
um you know when I was talking about
that section e where it says only if and
then it has additional requirements for
acknowledgment of data and might might
and the staff has said that the
department not only has the authority
they have the duty to inform and get
acknowledgments
if I understood you correctly that's
what you said is that it is the
Department's Duty
and if you don't like it we've got to
clean us there's some statutes we should
clean up I would say
um any other comments from the
Department we do have some public
testimony representative Cushman
thank you
thank you madam chair uh Leah Cushman
representing where endearing
um I serve on the house Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
and was a part of
um the process of amending this bill
um and can speak to the legislative
intent the intent was to strictly remove
the notary requirement and I believe
that this form that is being proposed in
this interim uh administrative rule
proposal
um steps well outside the bounds is that
which version of the form are we talking
about the ones there appear to be the
proposed rule the the one with the I
understand the risk of Contracting the
disease I understand
um is if you have if that's excuse me
for interrupting but
is that the rule that that the form that
you are the department is proposing to
bring forward yes which one it has the
one that the boxing the department
that is the rule you intend to bring
forward okay thank you
um we were confused by the shortcut yes
my mistake
um so
I have some issues with this form
because I think it's well outside of the
bounds of
um the legislative intent and while they
do have the right to require
acknowledgments this this makes it so
that in order to be granted an exemption
they must you know acknowledge these
certain things and that is not outlined
in the statute the statute is very clear
it's one sentence you know the parent
the student uh
child Shelby has not been immunized
because of religious beliefs period
that's it that's all the form should say
um
you know the old form that they had did
not require all of these things and the
only thing that changed in the statute
was striking the word notarized so I I
don't understand the logic logical leap
there where well we got rid of the
notarization requirement and now we can
require all of these acknowledgments
um it doesn't add up so
um I think that on if the form is just a
suggested form and that parents can make
their own that that should be stated
somewhere
um I I think that this form that's
proposed should be rejected based on
those extra requirements
um it should not feature the word
requests or certificate either because
it's not really a request you are
exerting your right to an exemption and
it should just state that you know my
child is exempt based on our sincere
religious beliefs
um it shouldn't require a listing of
vaccinations I see that as an
intimidation tactic parents will feel
fear your religious Inquisition or
scrutiny based on having to procure that
information and that that there can be
religious reasons to reject want to
object to one vaccination and not others
some are made through research on
aborted fetal cells some are not some
contain are grown in Monkey kidney cells
some are not so there are different
reasons that parents May object for
religious beliefs to different
vaccinations and under the statute it's
not required for them to disclose that
School nurses when they receive medical
records they can request the
immunization records and if they're not
a complete immunization record you know
there's some missing they can they can
note that when they receive them along
with the exemption
um it doesn't it shouldn't be on this
form as as a requirement to
um to exert that right to an exemption
there's also no need for an address
phone number grade all that the schools
already have that school nurse has that
information all that should really be
required as a name and maybe date of
birth and lastly the acknowledgment of
risk to yourself and other students that
that's an intimidation tactic as well
those statements are not only
self-incriminating
but they also also the risk of
Contracting or transmitting a
communicable disease is usually not at
the is not relevant to the religious
reasons and someone's sincere religious
beliefs for objecting to a vaccination
so again that's totally inappropriate
and there's no statutory authority to
add those statements to the religious
exemption form especially as a as a
requirement so either they need to be
removed or it needs to be very clear on
the form that it's just a suggested form
and that parents can submit their own
form that's just the very simplified
language without all of the um coerced
statement acknowledgments and I as far
as the form that was uploaded yesterday
to the website I have no problem with
that and nor with the exclusion language
I think it's
um that's pretty much in line with the
statute and and they have the you know I
think that form
um as long as the rule says shall be
exempt in the actual rule then that's
aligned and it and it works it fits
director Morrow uh Madam chair I would
agree with the representative if the
only Bill in play here was 1065. that's
specifically deals with removing the
notarization requirement it's 1487 that
has the other requirements it requiring
acknowledgment by the parents
thank you
Madam chair but again that's two
different rules we're talking about here
we're talking about e uh you know
h-e-p-30113 which is dealing with the
image which is dealing with the
exemption language but then you go on as
an entirely different role under
307.07 which is dealing with the
um the removal from the registry so
those two aren't interplayed at all
they're two separate rules so the
acknowledgment piece the statutory
requirement of 1487 for acknowledgment
is in 307 in uh I mean uh 307.07 that is
the registry conversation however the
1035 conversation which is uh 301 13
doesn't have any requirement for
acknowledgment in the statute at all so
I want to make sure we're talking about
two different statutes two different
sections of law one does have an
acknowledgment requirement when you're
asking to remove yourself from the
registry the other one doesn't not have
a requirement of acknowledgment
okay we can we go around like this for a
while
does anyone have emotion I move to
object to the rule
on the basis of and the basis of it
exceeds statutory Authority
motion by lying second by
Burstein and representative you have a
comment
okay
any discussion comments represent
Senator Prentice thank you chair McGuire
so just
I want to clarify I'm I'm hearing from
staff even though I have heard
Representatives Lang Lang's
comments about two different two
different statutes
is or is do they have the authority or
not
Mike
um
because this part of it been pondered
that way or was this all Consolidated
into one form for a reason
I I think the department have to answer
that and
I guess representative Lang's last
comments do raise a question in my mind
and I think the department might be able
to better clarify that
Department
I apologize and what
um
did you need the department to clarify
the acknowledgments on the forms
statement was the acknowledgment is a
requirement under RSA 1487 for the
removal that parents are acknowledging
get information or acknowledge certain
uh informational facts
um however under 1035 there was no
additional requirements made under that
bill to require informational facts or
acknowledgment of anything strictly that
a parent has the right to request a
religious exemption and we're adding new
requirements that aren't weren't in the
bill at Arnon statute and the you know
House Bill 1487 is about withdrawals
from the registry
and one can
it's you have to make these
um comments but withdrawal from the
registry is not the same as exempting
yourself from receiving the vaccinations
correct we did do that in one rule
package so it could be one interim Rule
and go forward at the same time we do
understand that that is two separate
rules two separate
issues yes
we did that for ease of having it in one
package together okay so
um and with respect to the
understandings
um on the religious exemption
certificate form that we're putting
forward uh we are happy to remove those
Madam chair yeah because I'm trying now
so I guess my question becomes
is that if we were looking at this
this new rule 1301 13 interim Rule and
you stop that where you have the the S
the number and change it to the August
of 22. period and stopped there and
removed everything else down to section
two is that what you're recommending so
with respect to yes I apologize I was
just strictly looking at the form
um so with respect to that in removing
those understandings uh from that first
form that's in AGP 301 13e we would then
um end
I apologize I'm just trying to you would
delete the three we would delete the
understandings
um and I believe you guys may have
acknowledgment that they are yeah all of
those three yeah and would we go back to
using the form that you have currently
posted the August 22nd form which is
this one
that doesn't require the medical data
which again is not is outside of statute
I apologize
we're fine yes so we are fine with
removing um so it would be e one and two
and all the middle acknowledgments and
using the August 22nd form no we would
remove it from the September 22 form
yes
well Senator gray and then Senate
Apprentice oh
so as I understand
choose to go this way then the
appropriate
motion would be conditionally proved is
that correct
they already have official request
if it's clear I'm sorry
I'm sorry they already have a
conditional approval request and this
could be added to that as long as it's
explicitly clear what the language is
going to be
okay so that you
is that okay I'm just trying to
determine if I have to withdraw if I
withdraw my objection based on what
they've said and I'm trying to make sure
it's clear to to the okay the motion as
we stay as I understand it would be to
conditionally accept the conditional
approval response with the following
addition additional comments namely to
delete those three paragraphs on risks
from the form yep and in the rule text
and in the rule yes
and eliminate the list of vaccines is
that part part of your agreement or
yours we weren't that was not something
that we proposed but
you'd have to change the uh
the form also to indicate that those
things are on the form
thank you I just wanted to add um would
it be there many there are many folks
that do religiously exempt from
vaccinations that
um would understand the risk of two
other children if there were be an
outbreak so we'd be open to having the
list of vaccinations with the check box
be optional as a first suggestion
because there are folks that don't have
a problem of having that information
reported to the school nurse but it is
important information to have for public
health reasons so I would just suggest
that if if possible okay for
consideration thank you
is that acceptable that it's an optional
list of vaccines
I think we really need to see yeah I
think Madam chair I think we're getting
so deep into the weeds and without
seeing a physical form I'm going to con
I think I'm gonna stick with my
objection and let them come back next
month with another conditional approval
or some rule or something uh response to
the objection so we're making an
objection to the form based on they want
to see it
Senator Francis thank you chair McGuire
I just think we need
the clean form
um I don't want to necessarily object or
approve I don't know what the proper
Pathway to go is I think that the
department already has this in play and
now on it feels a little bit
respectfully on the fly like we're going
to eliminate this we're gonna put this
in I agree thank you so so would you
would the department be able to have a
revised form and a revised rule for our
continued meeting on and yes thank you I
think that's the best way to go because
it sounds like we've more or less
reached agreement but we'd all like to
confirm that and I do just want to
confirm before we go back um so we're on
the same page that we will remove those
understandings from the form and the
rule in make the
um vaccinations that you are exempting
from being optional
um and I trust you will post
um you will either take the form off
your website or say this is a suggested
form you can
parents you can just send a letter and I
do want to point out if anybody is
looking at the administrative rules
webpage you will see these forms because
we do Post
um what we're bringing forward just
noting that that it's a little different
than program uh web pages to the public
on the administrative rules website it's
clearly the yes proposal and not the
final rule on your website it's what
they've got to do to get the kid in
school
so it will be posted twice on our
website one on mine specifically almost
like how uh OLS post theirs as well okay
Madam chair yes just a matter of
procedure and cleaning up so there's
currently a motion and a second on the
floor to object and is that and as a is
that the proper course so that they can
come back and clarify the objection and
clarify the rule and clean it up next
month yes they have a con I believe they
can come forward with a revised
conditional approval request
if the goal was to postpone to the
continued meeting rather than object
yeah I think that we're postponing the
action on that on that existing motion
to the continued beating until we can
see what they come up with
the continued meeting is October 6th
right yeah
yeah and the motion will remain until
it's taken up so the motion we're
picking up is to object unless they come
back with something get better that we
like
yes is that what I'm understanding yes
I'm cool with that
okay
agreeable we will await your response
thank you and thank you is there any
other business that needs to be taken
care of
um just for the committee's benefit I
wanted to apologize for the all the
postponed items we had a backlog from
last month and because of Staff
illnesses so we have suggested the
continued meeting to get rid of that
backlog and hopefully we don't have a
huge agenda in October
we do need to catch up and on that note
we have hired somebody to replace Diane
she will be starting in two weeks and
we're expecting Christina back in the
next week to two weeks all right we we
are expecting an efficient meeting on
the sixth
we're the only one uh one confusing
issue all right thank you
all right
by consensus we're adjourned
in
recess
we are recessed until the continued
meeting my my bad